hey youtubers is Charlie a lot of you
guys requested more age of Ultron videos
and a whole bunch of question so I
wanted to do a fun bonus video for a lot
of the big things that got cut out of
the movie Joss Whedon actually said when
he was getting ready to make age of
Ultron his goal was to make it shorter
than the first movie and they were
shorter by like a minute or two I'll say
spoiler warning if you guys haven't seen
the movie just because we'll be talking
about really specific stuff so starting
with number 5
Thanos end credits scene Whedon owned up
to the fact that he is not a big fan of
writing for Thanos so he just tries to
avoid him as much as possible whenever
it came time for James Gunn to use him
in guardians of the galaxy Whedon said
he chuckled a little bit and said enjoy
yourself good luck which is the
slightest hint of sarcasm you know of
course of course he's a big fan of James
Gunn and a big fan of guardians of the
galaxy it turned out great but one of
the big edicts from Marvel was capping
all these other phase 2 movies and that
demanded Thanos's presence his original
pitch for the movie had nothing to do
with the Infinity Gauntlet and during
the whole Phase two process whenever he
was advising on other films he went as
far to remove a lot of fan oohs from
guardians of the galaxy originally his
role in the film was closer to what
Ronan's was he was more of like the big
bad of the film and Whedon said no we
have to we have to hold off on this so
that's why Ronan became the big bad of
guardians of the galaxy the biggest
complaints that Whedon had about the
character is that he's kind of
unrelatable compared to other villains
he's like the guy behind the guy but
things were always headed in his
direction and of course Kevin Feige he's
like yeah you have to put the anos in
the movie so Thanos is in the end
credits scene it kind of makes you
wonder what's gonna happen whenever the
next director comes along and asked to
use Thanos in like a really big way like
maybe during Thor Ragnarok it could
either be really awesome or it could be
a nightmare from a story standpoint as
awesome as it is to work on Marvel films
sometimes things like this characters
like this could be big road blocks
moving on to number four Loki and
Heimdall and credit scene Heimdall was
in the movie he made it into Thor's
vision but there was a whole other scene
with Loki that was shot and just cut out
during the final edit Whedon said the
movie just got way too overstuffed with
plots so he had to cut it out just
because it wasn't absolutely essential
to the story that he was telling it was
really only there to set up Thor
Ragnarok and you could argue the Thor's
vision
of the Infinity Gauntlet did that
already all that Loki's seen was meant
to be was Thorpe returning to Asgard I
did see there was a lot of questions
about Thor's visions like you know what
what he was saying in what they were
setting up the Heimdall scene was of a
post-apocalyptic asgaard he was seeing
it after Ragnarok all his friends were
dying and things were in chaos the
flashes that he got of the Infinity
Gauntlet with the gems in it were just
part of that as if they were the cause
of Ragnarok that doesn't mean that
that's gonna be going on in Thor
Ragnarok although I think it'll have
something to do with the plot of the
movie I've already done a video for that
movie so I'll include a link in the
description but the movie is kind of
like Thor's version of Winter Soldier
crossed with Jack Kirby's Ragnarok so
Mike my Thor video that I did is all
about Jack Kirby's Ragnarok that'll
explain that story yes it's a bummer the
Tom Hiddleston had to sit Avengers age
of Ultron not because he's a great actor
he's a lot of fun it's low-key but he is
gonna be all over Thor 3 so don't worry
I know there's also a lot of questions
about how fan O's got that gauntlet at
the end if it's supposed to be an Odin's
vault the movie is probably gonna
address that Thor Ragnarok will address
that sometimes it all makes sense after
the final movie is released sometimes
they kind of derp along the way with the
logic there really isn't a lot of
context for like the time frame where
that Thanos post-credit scene takes
place it could be in the future it could
be in the present day they haven't
really confirmed that on to number three
mystery woman at Thor's reflecting pool
whenever they released the first trailer
everyone was pointing at this woman just
wondering who she might be
is it Halle is it someone else she's at
the reflecting pool that Thor took Erik
Selvig too so she's probably tied to
Asgardian mythology so if you're just
going with that context then it probably
is Halle but a lot of people thought it
also might be someone from Wakanda so it
could be that to Kevin Feige just said
that it really was no one it was just an
interesting image that marketing saw and
pulled for the trailer the people that
make the trailers aren't typically the
people that work on the film's is
usually the marketing department that
makes the trailers so a lot of times
what you'll see is scenes in trailers
that will never make it to the final cut
of a film that's number two Captain
Marvel is a member of the New Avengers
if you remember that scene at the end of
the movie where it pans up in Scarlet
Witch in her New Avengers costume those
were actually shot as visual effects
plates for Captain Marvel
they hadn't cast her yet when they shot
that so they were like well we'll cast
her and we'll put her in later it's
amazing how much you can change a film
after the film itself has been shot
the reason they cut her out is because
Kevin Feige just felt like it was too
soon to introduce her and when they did
introduce her they wanted to do it in a
much bigger way and this felt like it
would have been too offhanded like oh
yeah here's this you know huge character
big deal so Captain Marvel probably
gonna show up during Captain America
Civil War
spider-man is another good example that
they opted to not tag the end of the
film with any of that they just weren't
ready for it they did announce that he's
actually gonna be showing up in Captain
America's Civil War we don't know what
that roles gonna look like he could be
offered membership in the Avengers by
the end of the film whether or not the
Avengers still exist right now the two
big actors that are looking at our Tom
Holland and asa butterfield I feel like
either those choices would be acceptable
so I'm not gonna get super excited until
they finally confirm an actor
and finally the number one cut made to
Avengers age of Ultron the grey Hulk
this is actually a much bigger deal than
a lot of the other cuts because Joss
Whedon was actually building a big arc
of the film around hope becoming grey
he said that late in the editing stages
he came to the realization that it was
more of a plot device that could be
turned into its own movie so he went to
Kevin Feige and said I think we should
cut out gray Hulk you can just use this
in another movie so like the next likely
place they would do great hulk would be
Avengers infinity war if you're not
familiar with the grey Hulk the Hulk
originally whenever Stanley first
created him he was gray he was supposed
to be green but because of a coloring
error he wound up gray so his first
issue incredible hook number one he
started in his gray issue number two is
when he turned green
Stanley turned it into like an
interesting part of the mythology so
gray Hulk is like a slightly less angry
more cognitive version of the Hulk think
talking Hulk one that can communicate
beyond grunts so you can see how that
might have been really interesting with
you know Bruce
Natacha romance that was going on in the
film their relationship the green hook
that appeared in issue number two became
the savage Hulk he get angrier much
faster but would also proportionately
lose parts of his intelligence there
been various points throughout the
comics that have explored smart Hulk
Bruce Banner going code green while
being able to maintain his genius
intellect for those of you that read
x-men access there's also another
version of The Hulk - they made this
joke that it's the hoax version of the
Hulk like if the Hulk itself hooked out
he's basically like the most evil
version of Hulk you could possibly see
if you want to read like a really
awesome gray Hulk storyline just read
Jeff loves Hulk gray it was a six-issue
miniseries the artworks amazing in the
titles of each of the issues is really
interesting - it starts with like a is
for Apple and it gets to issue 6 F her
father so you get you know very cat's in
the cradle but Mark Ruffalo has been
really open about possible directions to
take a Hulk solo film there just like
this really interesting relationship
that Bruce Banner has with the Hulk
himself Mark Ruffalo is mostly known for
doing really personal psychological
indie films so it makes sense that he
would want to do a Hulk film that deals
more with that kind of stuff how does
Banner feel about the Hulk and how does
the Hulk feel about Banner so here's my
big question for you guys
you know what thing that they cut out of
the film do you really want to see on
the DVD bonus features there are a
couple things they probably won't do
like their plan I'm gonna put grey Hulk
on the bonus features most likely what
they'll do is they'll include that
low-key scene that they cut out and just
extended versions of scenes that they
cut way down most of the stuff they cut
down are just extra bits inside scenes
then you have like big arcs that they
cut out like grey Hulk I know a lot of
you guys have also asked me about
Quicksilver - like will he come back
which gems do they have what's going on
as of right now the only gems that they
don't have or the time gem which is time
travel which would be an easy way to
bring Quicksilver back and there's the
soul gem if you're wondering about which
gem is which just going in chronological
order the Marvel phases the tesseract is
the space gem the mind gem was in Loki's
staff I know everyone was confused about
the colors so the staff is blue the gem
is yellow the reason it didn't look
yellow is because it was covered in a
casing that was blue the power gem was
the one in guardians of the galaxy and
the reality gem was the aether in Thor
the dark world some of you have
requested some infinity gem bonus video
so I might I might do like some fun
comic-book history of infinity gem
videos in the future
so be sure to subscribe to get those if
there's any like other specific bonus
videos feel free to make requests we
have all the time in the world what I'm
going to star
doing now is because ant-man is only a
couple months away I'll do some ant-man
specific videos and then some Captain
America's Civil War stuff Scarlet Witch
has already confirmed that she's coming
back for Civil War they'll probably
bring vision back too but he's
unconfirmed hopefully you guys have had
a chance to see age of Ultron you can
actually click here for my breakdown
with spoilers and Easter eggs and you
can click here for the flash gorilla
grodd trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys this weekend